>> AMERICANS HELD HOSTAGE.
ABANDONED BEHIND ENEMY LINES.
DAY 51.
>> Sean: DE 51, OUR FELLOW
AMERICANS, THAT'S RIGHT,
ABANDON.
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS.
GREEN CARD HOLDERS ARE ELIGIBLE
TO BE IN THIS COUNTRY ABANDONED.
AFGHAN ALLIES, TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF THEM, ABANDONED.
THEIR FAMILIES ABANDONED BEHIND
ENEMY LINES THANKS TO JOE BIDEN
INTIMATE IS MORE CLEAR THAN EVER
JOE BIDEN AND HIS RADICAL
SOCIALIST FRIENDS ARE
COMPLETELY, TOTALLY INCOMPETENT
AND CLUELESS AND HAVE NO DESIRE
TO HELP BAIL OUT OUR FELLOW
AMERICANS.
THEY CAUSED THIS.
THIS IS ENTIRELY PREVENTABLE.
THEY ARE NOT LIFTING A FINGER TO
HELP AMERICANS IN NEED.
EVERYTHING THEY DO BECAUSE IT IS
AN UNMITIGATED DISASTER.
LOOK AT THE RECORD.
AFGHANISTAN, THE BORDER,
COVID-19, LABOR DAY LAST YEAR
VERSUS THIS YEAR.
300% INCREASE.
LOOK AT THE ECONOMY, LOOK AT
INFLATION.
LOOK AT ELIMINATING ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE THAT WE HAD
ACHIEVED UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN 75 YEARS.
WE ARE PAYING ABOUT $1.50 MORE A
GALLON AND JOE IS BEGGING OPEC
TO PRODUCE MORE ENERGY.
YOU COULD ASK TEXAS AND OKLAHOMA
AND NORTH DAKOTA AND ALASKA.
THEY CAN INCREASE THEIR
PRODUCTION AND GUESS WHAT, WE
COULD BE ENERGY INDEPENDENT
AGAIN.
YOU CAN SECURE THE BORDER,
FINISH THE WALL.
KEEP THE REMAINED IN MEXICO
POLICY.
THAT PROBLEM WOULD BE SOLVED
TOO.
SHOULD GO BACK AND GET OUR
FELLOW AMERICANS IN AFGHANISTAN.
BIDEN'S APPROVAL RATINGS WITH AN
ALL-TIME LOW AND THIS YEAR AT
SPORTING EVENTS ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, JIMMY KIMMEL, PAY
ATTENTION, GUESS WHAT.
THEY HAVE BEEN CHANTING THE
FOLLOWING.
F JOE BIDEN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> [BLEEP]
JOE BIDEN.
[BLEEP] JOE BIDEN.
>> Sean: THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS A TRAIN WRECK.
DEMOCRATS ARE IN A CIVIL WAR AND
WE, YOU THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE
NO REASON TO BE HAPPY OVER ANY
ELECT END OVER THE WEEKEND MORE
CHANTS.
LOOK AT TALLADEGA SPEEDWAY.
>> YOU ALSO TOLD ME, YOU CAN
HEAR
>> Sean: THE MEDIA MOB DOING
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO PROTECT
JOE BIDEN.
FIRST IT WAS THE CANDIDATE
PRODUCTION PROGRAM.
NOW IT'S THE PRESIDENTIAL
PROTECTION PROGRAM, TASK GOING
MORE IMPOSSIBLE BY THE HOUR.
ANOTHER CRISIS FOR JOE BIDEN,
HIS INSANE SPENDING BILLS,
SOCIALISM BILLS, THEY ARE STUCK
IN LIMBO.
THEY CANNOT BE PASSED THE
MOMENT.
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE ANY TIME IN
THE NEAR FUTURE.
MAJORITIES IN THE HOUSE, SENATE,
DEMOCRATS ARE UNABLE TO PASS
THEIR OWN TRILLION DOLLAR
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL AS WELL AS
THEIR RADICAL NEW GREEN DEAL
SOCIALIST FILM.
$3.5 TRILLION, THERE BUILD BACK
BETTER PROPOSAL.
THAT RAISES TAXES ON ALL OF US.
THE HOLDUP, OF COURSE WE HAVE A
CIVIL WAR STANDOFF BETWEEN
LIBERAL DEMOCRATS AND THE MORE
SOCIALIST BORDERING ON COMMUNIST
DEMOCRATS.
ON FRIDAY BUT MANY ARE CALLING A
WEIRD, HOLLOW GESTURE.
JOE BIDEN DID NOTHING.
HE LIMPED OVER TO THE CAPITAL
AND ENCOURAGED HIS FELLOW
DEMOCRATS TO GET ALONG AND PLAY
NICE.
ACCORDING TO A POLITICAL
REPORTER, JOE WAS WILLING TO
TAKE QUESTIONS FROM CONGRESSMEN
AND SENATORS ON THE PRESS, HIS
STAFF.
OH, GOING TO GET IN TROUBLE.
THEY GET MAD AT ME.
THEY ARE GOING TO YELL AT ME IF
I TAKE A QUESTION.
I'M NOT ALLOWED.
JOE, YOU'RE THE PRESIDENT.
IT'S A MUST AS OF JOE BIDEN
ISN'T IN CHARGE.
HIS STAFF KNOWS THAT HE'S A
COGNITIVE MESS.
WE KNOW FOR A FACT THAT RADICAL
SOCIALISTS RULING THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WITH AN IRON
FIST.
PER USUAL, THEY ARE DEFINITELY
NOT PLAYING NICE.
LOOK AT THIS IN ARIZONA.
ONE UNHINGED GROUP OF ACTIVISTS
INCLUDING SEVERAL ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS STACKING DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR KYRSTEN SINEMA.
THEY CHASED HER INTO A BATHROOM
STALL AND THEY STAYED OUTSIDE
THE STALL AND KEPT FILMING.
WOW.
>> WE NEED TO BUILD BACK BETTER
PLAN RIGHT NOW.
>> WE NEED SOLUTIONS.
THE BUILD BACK BETTER PLAN HAS
THE SOLUTIONS WE NEED.
>> Sean: STAND THERE AND FILM
WHILE SHE IS GOING TO THE
BATHROOM.
SENATOR SINEMA, ONE OF ONLY TWO
DEMOCRATS REFUSING TO
RUBBER-STAMP GUIDANCE IN SAYING
AND IT IS INSANE.
WE CAN'T AFFORD IT.
THESE POLICIES WILL FAIL.
FALSE PROMISES.
YOU'LL GET UP YOUR FREEDOM.
IT WILL RESULT IN MORE POVERTY,
LIKE EVERY SOCIALIST UTOPIA IN
THE PAST HAS DONE.
3.5 TRILLION.
THERE ARE ECO-SOCIALIST AMNESTY
FOR ALL SPENDING BILL.
SHE IS CALLING OUT DEMOCRATIC
LEADERSHIP FOR THEIR
"INEXCUSABLE, DEEPLY
DISAPPOINTING ACTIONS."
SENATOR SINEMA'S COLLEAGUE,
JOE MANCHIN, ALSO REFUSING TO
SIGN OFF ON THIS MONSTROSITY.
THE LIBERAL DEMOCRAT FROM
WEST VIRGINIA WILL ONLY COMMIT
TO A MERE $1.5 TRILLION BILL.
OKAY.
SOME LEVEL OF FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY I GUESS.
I DON'T AGREE SHOULD BE SPENDING
A PENNY ESPECIALLY AFTER ALL THE
MONEY WE HAD TO SPEND AS IT
RELATES TO THE WORST PANDEMIC
SINCE 1917 AND '18.
EVEN MANCHIN IS CONFRONTED BY
ACTIVISTS ON HIS HOUSE VOTE ON
THE POTOMAC.
FIRST, YOU MIGHT BE WONDERING,
WHAT DOES JOE BIDEN THINK ABOUT
HIS FELLOW DEMOCRATS BEING
STALKED AND HARASSED BY OTHER
DEMOCRATS?
YOU WOULD THINK MAYBE JOE BIDEN
WOULD SPEAK OUT, RIGHT?
ACCORDING TO JOE, IT'S JUST PART
OF A PROCESS.
FOR THOSE THAT DON'T ENJOY THE
SECRET SERVICE PROTECTION THAT
HE ENJOYS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> JOE MANCHIN HAD PEOPLE
KAYAKED TO HIS BOAT.
SENATOR SINEMA WAS CHASED INTO A
RESTROOM.
DO YOU THINK THOSE TACTICS ARE
APPROPRIATE QUESTIONING >> I
DON'T THINK THEY ARE APPROPRIATE
BUT IT HAPPENS TO EVERYBODY.
THE ONLY PEOPLE THAT IT DOESN'T
HAPPEN TO OUR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SERVICE -- SECRET SERVICE.
IT'S PART OF THE PROCESS.
SEE YOU AND YOU WON'T STICK UP
FOR YOUR FELLOW SENATORS.
I GUESS IT'S ALL PART OF THE
PROCESS.
YOU GETTING F JOE BIDEN'D ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY.
GETTING VIDEOTAPED IN A BATHROOM
STALL.
IS THAT PART OF THE PROCESS YOU
SUPPORT?
WHAT HAPPENED TO STANDING UP FOR
A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO PRIVACY.
WHAT ABOUT SHOWING UP AT
SOMEONE'S HOUSE AND SHOUTING
THEM DOWN WHERE THEY LIVE?
THAT'S PART OF THE PROCESS?
WHAT IF SOMEONE CAME TO YOUR
BASEMENT IN YOUR MIDDAY NAP?
IT'S NOT APPROPRIATE.
IT'S WRONG.
THE IT'S UNETHICAL.
YOU SHOULD'VE STUCK UP FOR BOTH
MANCHIN AND SINEMA.
MOB RULE IS NEVER PART OF THE
PROCESS BUT THAT'S RIGHT, YOU
WOULDN'T EVEN TALK ABOUT THE 534
RIOTS IN THE SUMMER OF 2020.
DEMOCRATS ONLY WANT TO TALK
ABOUT JANUARY 6TH.
THEY DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE RIOTS THAT KILLED DOZENS OF
AMERICANS, INJURED THOUSANDS OF
COPS, PELTED WITH BRICKS AND
ROCKS AND BOTTLES AND MOLOTOV
COCKTAILS AND PEOPLE, DOZENS OF
PEOPLE KILLED.
THOUSANDS OF COPS INJURED.
JOE BIDEN, IT'S WHAT HE'S BEEN
AN ENTIRE LIFE.
DISHONEST, LIFELONG SWAMPS WERE
POLITICIAN INGRAINED WITH ALL
WAYS SWAMP.
JOE BIDEN JUST CAN'T STOP LYING
ABOUT $3.5 TRILLION BILL BACK
BETTER BILL.
IT'S BUMPER STICKER AND A SLOGAN
AND A LIE.
HE IS SOMEONE THIS CLAIMING,
STILL CLIMBING.
PEOPLE ON HIS STAFF ARE CLAIMING
THAT WE SPEND $3.5 TRILLION IT
WILL COST YOU NOTHING.
THAT'S A LIE.
EVEN "THE WASHINGTON POST"
ACCUSED BIDEN OF LYON, GAVE HIM
A FEW PINOCCHIO